the first nor'easter of the season is
affecting more than 30 million people
forecasters call it another bomb cyclone
and it's happening right after the first
one blasted the west coast flooding
could cause trouble across the northeast
with rain likely to fall throughout the
day we can expect
three to six inches of rain plus 40 to
50 miles an hour of wind new york and
new jersey's governor has declared a
state of emergency ahead of the storm
mulla lange is in long beach new york
along the atlantic ocean mola good
morning
good morning overnight this nor'easter
began soaking the region with one to
three inches of rain still coming down
some areas even higher of course wind
definitely a part of the story across
the region the rainfall steadily
continues to drop and conditions are
expected to deteriorate throughout the
day the flash flood watch is in effect
for more than 31 million people in new
jersey crews cleared drains and handed
out sandbags to keep potential rushing
waters out and officials are hoping to
be as prepared as possible to avoid a
repeat of the deadly tropical storms the
remnants of hurricane ida that hit the
region this past summer when record
rainfall killed more than 50 people many
of those victims were trapped in their
homes or cars due to the flash flooding
the severe weather that slammed the
midwest on sunday has now moved here to
the northeast and is combining with a
coastal storm to create this the first
nor'easter of the season more than a
dozen tornadoes ripped through missouri
and illinois this past weekend
devastating winds caused extensive
damage to homes and businesses and a
maine electrical substation this
nor'easter striking today comes as
thousands of people in california are
still in the dark as a massive cleanup
effort continues there that system still
moving east and could be here as soon as
friday
and molo you know it's tough when you
have to use that plastic bag over the
microphone thank you so much